- Bienvenue dans Comprendre l'Information
et le Calcul Quantiques.
Je m'appelle John Watrous, et je suis directeur technique
de l'Éducation chez IBM Quantum.
C'est la deuxième leçon de la série. Si tu n'as pas encore
regardé la première leçon, assure-toi de la voir.
Nous allons nous appuyer directement sur ce dont nous avons parlé
dans la première leçon, donc il est important de bien
comprendre ce contenu avant d'aborder cette leçon.
Sache aussi que la série
comprend du contenu sous forme de manuel en plus des vidéos, et tu peux trouver un lien
vers ce contenu
dans la description de la vidéo. C'est la leçon deux de
l'unité un de la série.
L'unité un couvre les bases
de l'information quantique.
Dans la leçon précédente, nous avons parlé de l'information quantique dans le contexte de systèmes individuels, ce qui signifie que nous avons un
système qui stocke de l'information
et nous décrivons comment
il fonctionne de façon isolée.
Nous avons passé pas mal de
temps sur l'information classique, principalement pour établir un point de référence et mettre en évidence les
similarités mathématiques
entre l'information quantique et classique.
Nous avons aussi vu comment les états quantiques peuvent être représentés par des vecteurs, en particulier des vecteurs ayant
des entrées de nombres complexes et une norme euclidienne égale à un,
et nous avons discuté des
mesures en base standard et des opérations unitaires.
Dans cette leçon, nous allons élargir notre
vision à des systèmes multiples, chacun d'eux étant capable de
stocker de l'information quantique.
Ce n'est pas simplement une question de dire que chaque système individuel
fonctionne comme nous l'avons discuté la dernière fois, il y a un sens dans lequel le tout
est plus grand que la somme des parties, et c'est aussi vrai pour
l'information classique quand des probabilités sont impliquées.
Les systèmes multiples peuvent
interagir les uns avec les autres et ils peuvent être corrélés
entre eux, par exemple, et dans le contexte quantique, cela inclut la possibilité
que les systèmes soient intriqués, terme que tu
as peut-être déjà entendu.
L'intrication est un phénomène très
important en information quantique et nous aurons bien plus à en dire au fur et à mesure que la série avance.
Il existe un principe simple, cependant, qui nous offre beaucoup de prise pour réfléchir et
comprendre l'information quantique pour des systèmes multiples,
et c'est que nous pouvons toujours
prendre deux systèmes ou plus et les assembler ou simplement y
penser ensemble de façon conceptuelle
et les considérer comme s'ils forment
un seul système composé.
Et quand nous réfléchissons à un
système composé comme celui-ci, comme s'il était un seul système, nous reconnaissons qu'il doit être décrit d'une manière cohérente
avec tout ce que nous avons appris
dans la leçon précédente sur les systèmes individuels.
Nous verrons comment cela fonctionne
et comment la description de l'information quantique
pour des systèmes multiples émerge assez naturellement de la façon dont elle fonctionne pour les systèmes individuels
en s'appuyant sur ce seul principe. Voici un aperçu de la leçon et il se trouve être identique à l'aperçu de la leçon précédente,
mais cette fois notre attention
sera portée sur les systèmes multiples plutôt que les systèmes individuels.
Tout comme dans la leçon précédente et pour exactement les mêmes raisons, nous allons commencer avec
l'information classique.
Une fois encore, nous verrons
de très proches similitudes entre la façon dont l'information quantique
et classique fonctionnent au niveau mathématique.
Nous ne nous concentrerons généralement pas autant
sur l'information classique ou ne commencerons pas chaque leçon de la série par l'information classique comme ça.
Les leçons suivantes auront tendance à se concentrer bien plus exclusivement sur l'information et le calcul quantiques.
Mais ici, au début,
c'est une approche sensée et elle renvoie à l'idée que réfléchir à l'information classique
peut servir de précieuse source d'orientation pour comprendre l'information quantique.
Nous allons aussi discuter
de l'important concept de produit tensoriel dans
cette partie de la leçon.
Les produits tensoriels sont d'une importance capitale en information quantique, mais ils apparaissent aussi dans
le contexte classique.
Ensuite nous passerons à l'information quantique et tout comme dans la leçon précédente nous discuterons des états quantiques,
des mesures en base standard,
et des opérations unitaires cette
fois pour des systèmes multiples.
Nous allons commencer en parlant
des états classiques de systèmes multiples.
Rappelle-toi de la leçon précédente
qu'un état classique d'un système est une
configuration de ce système qui peut être reconnue et
décrite de façon non ambiguë
sans aucune incertitude ni erreur. Et en termes mathématiques, quand nous désignons un ensemble d'états classiques,
nous voulons simplement dire un ensemble fini et non vide.
Nous allons commencer notre discussion
des systèmes multiples en supposant que nous avons
seulement deux systèmes X et Y.
X a un certain ensemble d'états classiques que nous appellerons sigma tout comme
dans la leçon précédente, et Y a un certain ensemble d'états classiques
que nous appellerons gamma. L'ensemble sigma et gamma
pourrait être le même ensemble ou ils pourraient être différents,
mais nous leur donnons des noms différents, non seulement parce qu'ils
pourraient être des ensembles différents, mais aussi parce que ça nous aidera
à garder les choses claires si nous leur donnons des noms différents.
Nous trouverons qu'il est
assez facile de généraliser toute cette discussion de deux systèmes à un nombre quelconque de systèmes, mais
en commençant avec deux systèmes,
nous pouvons nous concentrer sur les idées fondamentales sans nous enliser dans les détails.
WEBVTT
Maintenant, imagine que nous
mettions X et Y côte à côte avec X à gauche et Y à droite, et que nous considérions ces deux systèmes ensemble
comme s'ils formaient un seul système composé.
Pour donner un nom à ce nouveau système, nous pouvons l'écrire comme une
paire ordonnée comme ceci, ou nous pouvons simplement juxtaposer
les deux lettres comme ça.
Les deux sont courants et nous pouvons
choisir celui que nous voulons ou celui qui est le plus pratique.
Dans les deux cas, nous le lisons comme XY.
Une question très naturelle
à poser à ce stade est quels sont les états classiques de ce nouveau système composé XY ?
Et la réponse à cette question est que l'ensemble d'états classiques de XY est le produit cartésien des
deux ensembles d'états classiques,
sigma et gamma, que tu
peux voir défini juste ici.
À un moment donné, X a un certain état classique
qui est un élément de sigma, et Y a un certain état classique
qui est un élément de gamma,
et nous pensons simplement
à ces deux états ensemble comme s'ils forment un seul état, et c'est précisément la notion
que le produit cartésien capture. Nous avons deux éléments,
un de chacun de nos ensembles, et nous voulons considérer
ces deux éléments ensemble
comme s'ils formaient un seul
élément d'un seul ensemble.
Pour être clair, il y a une hypothèse ici qui est que nous savons
lequel de nos systèmes est X et lequel est Y,
et il n'y a pas de confusion entre eux. Il n'est pas important que X soit physiquement à gauche
et Y à droite,
mais plutôt que les deux
systèmes sont distinguables et que nous avons décidé
de les ordonner ainsi juste pour pouvoir garder
la distinction entre eux.
Voici un exemple très simple où sigma est l'alphabet binaire et gamma est l'ensemble
contenant les quatre couleurs de cartes.
Si X stocke une valeur binaire et Y stocke l'une des quatre couleurs de cartes, alors il y a huit
états classiques possibles
de la paire XY, que tu
peux voir listés juste ici.
Pour plus de deux systèmes, cela se généralise de façon simple.
En particulier si X1 jusqu'à Xn sont des systèmes ayant des ensembles d'états classiques sigma un jusqu'à sigma n respectivement.
Alors si nous imaginons regrouper
les n systèmes ensemble et les considérer comme un seul système, l'ensemble d'états classiques est
donné par le produit cartésien
des n ensembles d'états classiques
sigma un jusqu'à sigma n.
Comme tu peux le voir ici à l'écran. Le produit cartésien
peut être défini ainsi pour n'importe quel nombre d'ensembles.
Par exemple, si nous avons trois systèmes et qu'ils partagent tous l'alphabet binaire comme ensemble d'états classiques, donc en d'autres termes nous avons trois bits,
alors il y a huit
états classiques possibles des trois bits considérés
ensemble comme un seul système et tu peux les voir listés juste ici.
Chaque système individuellement peut
être dans l'état zéro ou un, et nous parcourons toutes les
combinaisons possibles.
Un n-uplet d'états classiques peut alternativement être écrit comme une chaîne où nous supprimons les
parenthèses et la virgule comme tu le vois ici.
Et c'est particulièrement sensé quand nous considérons
les états classiques comme des symboles comme dans l'exemple très courant
de l'alphabet binaire
sur lequel nous revenons sans cesse. Parfois c'est très pratique de faire cela et ça tend à rendre
nos expressions plus simples
et moins encombrées. La notion de chaîne est en fait formalisée
en termes mathématiques à travers les produits cartésiens,
donc c'est vraiment juste
une notation alternative et non quelque chose de conceptuellement différent.
À titre d'exemple, disons que nous avons
10 bits X1 jusqu'à X10.
Cela signifie que l'ensemble d'états classiques des 10 bits ensemble,
que tu pourrais naturellement considérer comme un registre de 10 bits
dans un ordinateur par exemple,
est le produit cartésien décuplé
de l'alphabet binaire avec lui-même.
Et si nous écrivons ces états comme des chaînes, ils ressemblent à ce que tu vois
ici, il y en a 1 024,
donc bien sûr ils ne sont pas tous listés ici. Ces trois points ici
sont supposés indiquer qu'il y a un motif que tu peux déduire
et j'espère que tu comprends l'idée. Il y a une convention
que nous allons suivre pour ordonner les éléments
des ensembles de produits cartésiens,
et il est important de
la clarifier pour pouvoir représenter à la fois les états probabilistes et les états quantiques comme des vecteurs.
La convention est que
nous ordonnons les éléments des ensembles de produits cartésiens
lexicographiquement, ce qui signifie essentiellement un ordre de dictionnaire.
Plus précisément, nous partons de l'hypothèse que chacun des ensembles individuels dont nous prenons le produit cartésien a déjà son propre ordre
et nous considérons un
n-uplet ou une chaîne donné comme s'il était un mot et nous les ordonnons alphabétiquement.
Une autre façon de le dire est que les positions au sein d'un
n-uplet ou d'une chaîne diminuent en importance
de gauche à droite,
tout comme quand nous écrivons des nombres en utilisant les chiffres zéro à neuf.
Voici un exemple qui est
censé clarifier cela.
Si nous prenons le produit cartésien entre les ensembles contenant
un, deux et trois et l'alphabet binaire, nous obtenons un ensemble contenant six éléments
et ils sont listés ici dans l'
ordre décrit.
Tous les éléments ayant un
un en première position viennent avant tous les éléments ayant un deux en première position et ils viennent avant tous les éléments
WEBVTT
ayant un trois en première position. Et chaque fois que deux éléments
s'accordent sur la première position, on se rabat sur l'ordre
en deuxième position.
Donc c'est l'ordre que
nous utilisons pour les produits cartésiens.
Remarque que lorsque nous utilisons cette convention et que nous écrivons les n-uplets comme des chaînes, nous observons des motifs très familiers.
Par exemple, le produit cartésien de
l'alphabet binaire avec lui-même est ordonné comme tu le vois ici,
et tu peux considérer ces chaînes comme étant ordonnées numériquement si tu prends ces chaînes
comme des encodages binaires d'entiers non négatifs
et cela se généralise
à n'importe quelle longueur de chaîne. En passant aux états probabilistes, nous savons déjà depuis la leçon précédente
qu'un état probabiliste associe une probabilité à chaque état classique
d'un système donné.
Si nous avons un système composé où nous avons pris deux systèmes ou plus et que nous les considérons collectivement comme s'ils forment un seul
système comme nous venons de le discuter,
alors un état probabiliste
de ce système composé doit assigner des probabilités aux éléments du produit cartésien
des systèmes individuels,
des ensembles d'états classiques. C'est parce que c'est
l'ensemble d'états classiques du système composé.
Par exemple, en supposant
que X et Y sont des bits, nous avons cet exemple d'un
état probabiliste de XY.
La probabilité que les deux
bits soient à zéro est un demi et la probabilité que les deux
bits soient à un est un demi, et donc les deux bits ne sont jamais en désaccord.
C'est un état probabiliste valide de XY, et nous pouvons alternativement
l'écrire comme un vecteur
comme tu le vois ici et tu peux voir que nous
suivons la convention que j'ai décrite il y a un instant pour ordonner ces états classiques.
C'est un exemple d'un
état probabiliste où X et Y sont corrélés, et c'est le sens dans lequel le tout
est plus grand que la somme des parties. Comme je l'ai suggéré avant, ce n'est pas simplement que nous
avons un état probabiliste
de X et un état probabiliste de Y que nous assemblons, mais plutôt nous assemblons d'abord
les systèmes ensemble
et ensuite nous réfléchissons aux
états probabilistes du système composé.
Pour être plus précis à propos des
corrélations entre systèmes. Nous commençons par définir la
notion d'indépendance, qui est essentiellement l'
absence de corrélation.
Ici, au fait, le terme indépendance désigne
l'indépendance statistique par opposition à l'indépendance linéaire
des vecteurs par exemple.
C'est une notion fondamentale en
probabilité et statistiques.
Si nous avons deux systèmes X et Y et que nous avons un certain état probabiliste
de XY en tête, alors nous disons que X et Y sont indépendants.
Si la formule que tu
vois ici est vraie pour tout choix d'états classiques
a et b de X et Y.
Une façon d'interpréter cette
condition d'indépendance est qu'elle dit que la probabilité que X soit dans un état classique quelconque
et la probabilité que Y soit dans un autre état classique n'ont absolument
rien à voir l'une avec l'autre.
Donc, apprendre dans quel état
se trouve l'un des systèmes n'affecte pas les
probabilités associées aux états de l'autre système.
Si tu imagines choisir aléatoirement
un certain état classique de X selon une certaine procédure et ensuite choisir aléatoirement
un certain état classique de Y
selon une autre procédure qui n'est en aucune façon
liée à celle de X, comme par exemple si une personne lance une pièce de monnaie
et une autre personne dans une
pièce différente lance un dé, alors c'est la formule
que tu utiliserais pour obtenir les probabilités
pour différentes combinaisons
d'états à apparaître. Le point de la définition est que l'indépendance est
quand la formule est valide.
Quand nous pensons aux états probabilistes en termes de vecteurs de probabilité, il y a une formulation simple
de cette condition
plus précisément si nous avons un
état probabiliste de XY, que nous pouvons exprimer comme un
vecteur dans la notation directe
comme tu le vois ici. Alors dire que X et Y sont indépendants est équivalent à l'existence
de deux vecteurs de probabilité,
ket Phi et ket Psi qui au fait peuvent
simplement être lus comme Phi et Psi par souci de brièveté représentant
des états probabilistes de X et Y séparément qui satisfont cette égalité
que tu vois ici.
Pour tout choix de a et b, c'est essentiellement une
reformulation de la définition en termes de vecteurs.
Par exemple, voici un état probabiliste
d'une paire de bits XY pour lequel X et Y sont indépendants.
La condition requise
pour l'indépendance est vraie pour les vecteurs
que tu vois ici.
C'est-à-dire que la probabilité
pour chaque configuration possible des deux bits est donnée par le produit des probabilités correspondantes
pour les bits individuels.
Par exemple, la probabilité que les deux
bits prennent la valeur zéro est égale à un sixième, ce qui est égal à un
quart fois deux tiers,
et de même pour les
trois autres possibilités qui peuvent être vérifiées une par une.
Pour l'état probabiliste que nous avons vu précédemment d'autre part où nous
avons deux bits qui sont toujours en accord et prennent les valeurs zéro et
un avec une probabilité d'un demi
nous n'avons pas l'indépendance et c'est pourquoi nous disons que
les bits sont corrélés.
La corrélation signifie simplement
l'absence d'indépendance.
Une façon simple d'argumenter que les
deux bits ne sont pas indépendants est de supposer qu'ils le sont et d'en dériver une contradiction
plus précisément si les deux
bits étaient indépendants, il faudrait qu'il existe
des nombres q0, q1, r0 et r1
WEBVTT
représentant des probabilités
pour les deux bits individuels de sorte que ces équations
ici soient satisfaites.
Ce sont les probabilités
qui proviennent de notre vecteur et ce sont les
équations qui doivent être vraies par la condition d'indépendance,
mais si nous regardons cette
deuxième égalité ici, nous voyons qu'elle exige que
q0 fois r1 soit égal à zéro,
mais la seule façon que le
produit de deux nombres réels puisse être égal à zéro est si au moins l'un de ces
nombres lui-même est égal à zéro.
C'est parfois appelé
la propriété du produit nul des nombres réels.
Une autre façon de le dire est que le produit de deux nombres réels non nuls
est toujours non nul.
Donc cette égalité
ici implique que soit q0 est égal à zéro, soit r1 est égal à zéro,
mais d'après la première et la dernière égalité nous voyons qu'aucune de
ces deux alternatives ne peut être vraie.
Si q0 est égal à zéro, alors ce produit doit être égal à zéro, mais il n'est pas égal à zéro
et si r1 est égal à zéro,
alors ce produit doit être égal à zéro, mais ce n'est pas vrai non plus.
Donc nous avons une contradiction
et nous concluons que X et Y ne sont pas indépendants donc ils sont corrélés.
La notion d'indépendance
que nous venons de discuter et spécifiquement sa formulation en termes de vecteurs de
probabilité est étroitement liée
à une opération qui peut
être effectuée sur des vecteurs connue sous le nom de produit tensoriel.
Les produits tensoriels peuvent être
définis non seulement pour des vecteurs mais aussi pour des matrices
et en fait la notion de produit tensoriel peut être définie
pour beaucoup d'autres types d'
objets mathématiques également.
Ils peuvent être décrits
d'une façon assez abstraite qui est à la fois importante et
utile en mathématiques pures, mais nous pouvons aussi définir
des produits tensoriels pour des vecteurs
d'une manière très simple et concrète, et c'est la voie que
nous allons emprunter dans cette leçon.
Si nous avons deux vecteurs colonnes Phi et Psi écrits sous les formes que tu vois ici où sigma et gamma sont n'importe quel
choix d'ensembles d'états classiques
que nous voulons ou des indices si tu préfères, alors le produit tensoriel de ces vecteurs est le vecteur que tu vois juste ici.
Nous parcourons tous les éléments
du produit cartésien des deux ensembles, sigma et gamma, et l'entrée de ce
vecteur qui correspond
à chaque paire ab, qui est
écrite comme une chaîne ici, est égale au produit des entrées correspondantes
de ces deux vecteurs. En d'autres termes, l'entrée ab de Phi tensoriel Psi est le produit de l'entrée a
de Phi et de l'entrée b de Psi,
et c'est la signification de
ce qui est écrit ici.
En essence, c'est la même opération que nous venons de voir il y a quelques instants quand nous avons discuté de l'indépendance
et maintenant nous lui donnons juste un nom.
Voici exactement le même exemple
que nous avons vu il y a un instant écrit plus explicitement en
termes de produit tensoriel.
Une fois encore, nous avons qu'un sixième est égal à un quart fois un tiers, un douzième est égal à un quart
fois un tiers et ainsi de suite.
Ici, au fait, voici
quelques façons alternatives d'écrire le produit
tensoriel de deux vecteurs.
Quand nous utilisons la notation directe et que nous écrivons deux kets l'un à côté de l'autre comme ça, cela signifie le produit tensoriel.
Donc tu peux penser au produit tensoriel comme étant en quelque sorte la façon par défaut de multiplier deux vecteurs colonnes ensemble.
Ça n'aurait aucun sens
de considérer un produit de vecteurs colonnes comme ça en termes de multiplication matricielle parce que les dimensions ne fonctionnent pas,
donc il n'y a vraiment pas d'inquiétude
à avoir concernant l'ambiguïté ici.
Nous pouvons aussi écrire le
produit tensoriel comme ça à l'intérieur d'un ket et ça signifie
exactement la même chose.
C'est le produit tensoriel
des deux vecteurs.
Le premier est très courant et en fait il est peut-être plus courant d'écrire un produit tensoriel comme ça sans le symbole de produit tensoriel
que de l'inclure. Le second est
certainement beaucoup moins courant, mais il est parfois assez utile principalement
comme moyen d'éliminer le besoin
de parenthèses supplémentaires dans certaines situations.
Nous pouvons aussi exprimer
les produits tensoriels explicitement en termes de colonnes réelles de
nombres comme tu le vois ici,
si nous prenons le produit tensoriel de ces deux vecteurs colonnes ici, alors c'est le vecteur que nous obtenons
et tu peux voir que les entrées ici sont des produits des entrées
provenant de ces deux vecteurs.
L'ordre des entrées
du produit tensoriel est cohérent avec la
définition donnée il y a un instant à condition que nous suivions la convention
que j'ai décrite plus tôt pour ordonner les éléments
des ensembles de produits cartésiens.
Suivre cette convention est équivalent à considérer
les indices du premier vecteur comme ayant une signification plus élevée que les indices du second vecteur,
donc tu peux voir qu'en
parcourant les entrées du produit tensoriel, nous avons tous les produits impliquant la première entrée du
premier vecteur à gauche,
qui est alpha un. Puis tous les produits
impliquant la deuxième entrée du vecteur à gauche,
qui est alpha deux et ainsi de suite.
Voici un exemple où
le vecteur à gauche a trois entrées et le vecteur à
droite a quatre entrées donc nous pouvons voir plus
clairement ce qui se passe.
WEBVTT
Nous avons trois entrées dans le premier vecteur, donc nous commençons par écrire trois copies du second vecteur et ensuite nous multiplions chacune de ces copies
par l'entrée correspondante
dans le premier vecteur comme ça.
Nous faisons entrer les alphas comme ça, et ici nous
multiplions simplement des vecteurs par des scalaires
et finalement nous supprimons les
parenthèses des copies et nous formons un seul vecteur
colonne comme tu le vois ici.
En aparté importante remarque que nous avons les formules suivantes pour le produit tensoriel des
vecteurs de base standard.
Si nous prenons le produit
tensoriel du ket a et du ket b, que nous pouvons écrire avec
le symbole de produit tensoriel ou sans, comme tu le vois ici,
alors le résultat est simplement le ket ab.
Si nous voulons écrire ab comme une paire ordonnée plutôt qu'une chaîne, nous pouvons le faire et nous obtenons
cette expression ici,
mais c'est bien plus courant
d'écrire ceci ici où nous omettons la parenthèse
mais nous laissons la virgule.
Il y a un sens dans lequel
celui avec la parenthèse est peut-être plus correct, mais c'est une convention assez standard en mathématiques
que les parenthèses sont supprimées quand elles ne sont pas nécessaires ou utiles.
Tu peux considérer qu'elles sont implicites dans celui-ci et c'est juste moins encombré
et plus agréable à regarder.
Le produit tensoriel a
une propriété importante qui est qu'il est bilinéaire et ce que cela signifie c'est qu'il est linéaire
dans chacun des deux arguments à condition que l'autre soit fixe.
Plus en détail, il est
linéaire dans le premier argument ce qui est exprimé par ces deux équations que tu vois ici,
la première dit que
si nous ajoutons deux vecteurs, Phi1 et Phi2 et ensuite prenons
le produit tensoriel avec Psi, nous obtenons le même résultat que si
nous avions pris le produit tensoriel
avec Psi d'abord et ensuite additionné.
La deuxième dit que si
nous multiplions un vecteur Phi par un scalaire alpha et ensuite nous prenons le
produit tensoriel avec Psi,
le résultat est le même que si nous avions d'abord pris le produit tensoriel de Phi et Psi et ensuite multiplié le résultat par alpha.
Et nous avons aussi la linéarité
dans le second argument ce qui est pareil sauf que les rôles des deux arguments sont échangés.
Cette propriété de bilinéarité
est assez simple à vérifier à partir de la définition, mais c'est bien de l'écrire comme ça parce que nous utiliserons souvent
ces formules.
Remarque au fait que les scalaires flottent librement à travers les produits tensoriels dans le sens exprimé par ces
égalités que tu vois ici.
C'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas de différence
entre multiplier le premier argument par un
scalaire alpha dans ce cas multiplier le second
argument par ce scalaire
ou multiplier le tout
par ce scalaire.
Ces égalités découlent de
ces deux équations ici et parce qu'il n'y a pas de
différence entre ces vecteurs, nous pouvons simplement écrire l'
expression comme tu le vois ici
sans parenthèses parce
qu'il n'en est pas besoin.
Elles n'ajoutent pas de clarté
ni ne suppriment d'ambiguïté, donc nous les supprimons simplement et
nous obtenons une expression plus propre.
Tout cela se généralise
à trois systèmes ou plus.
Nous pouvons définir le produit tensoriel
de trois vecteurs ou plus en généralisant la formule
du produit tensoriel de deux vecteurs de façon naturelle,
que tu peux voir exprimée ici. Chaque entrée du produit tensoriel est donnée par le produit des entrées correspondantes
des vecteurs dont nous
prenons le produit tensoriel.
Une façon équivalente de
définir le produit tensoriel de trois vecteurs ou plus
est de le faire récursivement en se ramenant finalement à la définition
du produit tensoriel entre deux vecteurs. Donc si n est au moins trois, nous pouvons penser au
produit tensoriel de n vecteurs
Phi1 jusqu'à Phi n comme étant le produit tensoriel entre quel que soit le vecteur que nous obtenons en
prenant le produit tensoriel des n moins un premiers
d'entre eux avec le dernier vecteur,
et si tu veux savoir
ce qu'est le produit tensoriel des n moins un premiers vecteurs, tu appliques à nouveau la formule si n moins un
est au moins trois ou tu utilises la définition
d'avant si n moins un est égal à deux.
Les deux façons de penser
aux produits tensoriels de trois vecteurs ou plus sont équivalentes.
Cette fois quand nous avons
trois vecteurs ou plus dont nous prenons le produit tensoriel, nous n'utilisons pas le terme bilinéaire,
nous utilisons plutôt le terme multilinéaire,
mais l'idée est la même.
Le produit tensoriel est linéaire
dans chacune des positions à condition que les vecteurs dans
toutes les autres positions
soient fixés. En passant aux mesures
de systèmes multiples dans des états probabilistes,
nous obtenons immédiatement une spécification pour comment les mesures
fonctionnent pour des systèmes multiples en les considérant simplement collectivement comme des systèmes uniques
à condition que tous les
systèmes soient mesurés.
À titre d'exemple simple, supposons que nous avons deux
bits X et Y et collectivement ils sont dans cet état probabiliste
ici,
que nous avons vu avant. Naturellement, si nous mesurons
ces deux bits, nous obtiendrons le résultat 00
ce qui signifie un zéro pour la première mesure et un zéro pour la seconde mesure avec une probabilité d'un demi et nous obtiendrons le résultat 1,1
WEBVTT
avec une probabilité d'un demi également. C'est assez simple.
En essence, mesurer tous les systèmes est équivalent à mesurer
l'ensemble du système composé.
Si nous ne mesurons pas tous
les systèmes cependant, mais que nous mesurons seulement
certains des systèmes, alors la situation n'est
pas si immédiatement claire
en limitant notre attention encore une fois au cas de seulement deux
systèmes pour voir l'essence de ce qui se passe dans le
contexte le plus simple possible.
Nous pouvons poser la question suivante, suppose que nous avons deux systèmes, X et Y qui sont ensemble en tant que paire
dans un état probabiliste particulier.
Que se passe-t-il si nous mesurons
seulement X et que nous ne faisons rien à Y ?
Eh bien, nous pouvons répondre à cette question en utilisant quelques théorèmes de probabilité de base.
D'abord, nous savons que la probabilité que la mesure
donne un résultat particulier doit être donnée par cette formule
que tu vois ici.
Nous pouvons penser aux probabilités pour chacun des états classiques
de la paire XY comme si nous avions mesuré les deux et nous additionnons toutes les probabilités
qui sont cohérentes avec X étant dans l'état classique a
qui nous intéresse.
C'est pourquoi la somme ici porte juste sur les états classiques b de Y.
Une façon de penser à cette
formule est que la probabilité de voir un état classique particulier
de X si nous le mesurons
doit être cohérente avec la probabilité de voir cet état si
nous avions aussi mesuré Y, même si ce n'est pas le cas,
c'est très naturel et intuitif. La probabilité qu'une mesure de X donne un résultat particulier ne peut pas dépendre du fait que Y
ait aussi été mesuré
indépendamment du résultat.
Donc ça nous dit quelles
sont les probabilités pour les différents résultats
possibles de la mesure, mais qu'advient-il de Y ou de notre
connaissance de Y par conséquent ?
La réponse est qu'il pourrait encore
exister une incertitude sur l'état de Y par suite d'avoir mesuré X
et d'avoir obtenu un résultat particulier. Et cette incertitude est représentée par cette formule ici pour la probabilité conditionnelle
que Y est dans un état classique particulier
b, étant donné que X est dans un état classique,
quel que soit l'état classique a
que nous avons mesuré.
Pour être précis, la probabilité que Y soit
dans un certain état classique b, étant donné que X est dans l'état classique a,
est égale à la probabilité
que X soit dans a et Y soit dans b divisée par la probabilité que X
soit dans l'état classique a.
Donc si nous mesurons X, nous allons voir
différents états classiques avec des probabilités déterminées
par cette formule ici
et selon le résultat obtenu, nous pouvons encore avoir une incertitude sur l'état classique de Y et
cette incertitude est reflétée
par cette formule ici.
Il y a en fait une façon très simple
de reformuler tout cela et d'effectuer des calculs
pour des cas spécifiques en utilisant la notation directe
et ça fonctionne comme suit.
Nous commençons par écrire l'
état probabiliste de XY comme un vecteur comme ça, et
c'est complètement général.
Les entrées sont notées Pab et celles-ci peuvent être n'importe quels nombres tant que le vecteur entier
est un vecteur de probabilité.
Nous pouvons exprimer le ket ab comme un
produit tensoriel comme tu le vois ici et ensuite nous pouvons utiliser la
bilinéarité du produit tensoriel
et spécifiquement le fait qu'il est linéaire dans le second argument pour exprimer ce vecteur
comme tu le vois ici.
Ce que nous faisons c'est effectivement isoler les vecteurs de base standard
du côté gauche et mettre ce dont nous avons besoin
du côté droit
pour permettre cela parce que ça va révéler ce qui se passe quand nous
mesurons le premier système X.
Spécifiquement la probabilité
d'obtenir un résultat particulier a est la somme de toutes les probabilités qui apparaissent dans la
parenthèse à côté du ket a.
Et conditionnellement à l'obtention
d'un résultat particulier a, le vecteur de probabilité qui décrit quelle que soit l'incertitude qui reste à propos de Y
est le vecteur qui était dans
les parenthèses à côté de a.
Sauf que nous devons le normaliser pour en faire un vecteur de probabilité et c'est dire que
nous devons diviser ce vecteur
par la somme des entrées de ce vecteur pour former un vecteur de probabilité.
Ici au fait, la somme est prise sur tout
c dans gamma plutôt que b juste pour utiliser un nom de variable différent afin qu'il n'y ait pas de confusion
sur la portée des
variables si tu veux.
Les sommes au numérateur
et au dénominateur doivent être considérées comme des choses séparées et nous pouvons éviter toute chance
de confusion à ce sujet
en utilisant des variables différentes
pour les deux sommes.
Voici un exemple rapide pour
illustrer comment tout cela fonctionne.
Suppose que XY est une paire de bits dans cet état probabiliste ici pour comprendre ce qui se passe
quand nous mesurons le premier bit
et ne faisons rien au second, nous écrivons le vecteur comme tu le vois ici où les kets zéro et
un en première position
sont isolés tout comme
nous l'avons décrit il y a quelques instants.
La première possibilité est
que le résultat de la mesure est zéro et la probabilité
que cela se produise est la somme des probabilités
à l'intérieur des parenthèses
WEBVTT
qui sont mises en produit tensoriel avec le ket zéro. Donc nous obtenons un douzième plus un quart, ce qui fait un tiers et
conditionné sur le résultat zéro.
L'état probabiliste de Y
devient ce vecteur normalisé ou équivalemment divisé par la probabilité
que nous venons de calculer, et donc ce que nous obtenons c'est
ce vecteur ici.
La deuxième possibilité est que le résultat de la mesure est un et le calcul est
effectué de façon similaire en utilisant le second terme de l'expression
plutôt que le premier terme. Et si tu veux vérifier les détails, vas-y comme toujours et mets la vidéo sur pause pour te donner un moment pour le faire.
Tu peux effectuer les mêmes
sortes de calculs pour comprendre ce qui se passe quand
Y est mesuré plutôt que X.
C'est la même méthode avec une symétrie entre les deux systèmes.
Cette fois nous écrivons le
vecteur de probabilité comme ça, en isolant les vecteurs de base standard à droite comme tu le vois ici,
mais sinon ça fonctionne
exactement de la même façon.
Tu peux aussi utiliser cette méthode
pour plus de deux systèmes.
Ça peut devenir un peu
laborieux d'écrire toutes les expressions requises, mais conceptuellement c'est
exactement la même idée.
Enfin, pour la partie de la leçon
sur l'information classique, nous allons examiner les opérations
sur les états probabilistes
de systèmes multiples. En suivant le même raisonnement que nous avons vu plusieurs fois.
Nous concluons que les opérations probabilistes sur des systèmes multiples sont tout comme les opérations probabilistes sur des systèmes individuels représentées
par des matrices stochastiques.
Mais cette fois ces matrices
ont des lignes et des colonnes qui correspondent au produit cartésien des ensembles d'états classiques des systèmes individuels.
C'est-à-dire que nous considérons simplement
un système composé comme s'il était un système individuel et nous nous appuyons sur la description de comment les opérations probabilistes fonctionnent
pour les systèmes individuels de
la leçon précédente.
Voici un exemple d'une opération appelée une opération
NOT contrôlé sur deux bits X et Y.
C'est en fait une opération déterministe et la façon dont elle fonctionne est
que si X est égal à un, alors une opération NOT est effectuée sur Y
et sinon si X est égal
à zéro alors rien ne se passe.
Le bit X est parfois
appelé le bit de contrôle parce qu'il détermine si
l'opération NOT est appliquée à Y
et Y est appelé le bit cible parce que c'est le bit qui est affecté par l'opération NOT.
Tu peux aussi imaginer
d'échanger les rôles de X et Y de sorte que Y devienne le bit de contrôle
et X devienne la cible, mais c'est une opération différente
de celle décrite ici parce que l'opération n'est pas
symétrique entre X et Y.
Les deux sont appelées
des opérations NOT contrôlé, et nous devons simplement spécifier
lequel des bits est le bit de contrôle et
lequel est le bit cible.
Cette opération a l'action
que tu vois ici sur les états de base standard et tu peux vérifier cette
action par rapport à la définition
de l'opération. Et voici la représentation matricielle de l'opération.
Quand nous réfléchissons à cette opération, nous avons à l'esprit qu'il y a
ces deux bits séparés qui jouent les rôles que je viens de décrire avec
X étant le bit de contrôle
et Y étant le bit cible, mais il n'y a vraiment rien
à propos de cette action ici ou de cette représentation matricielle
qui exige que nous
considérions ces deux bits comme étant des bits séparés.
Nous pourrions alternativement
considérer cette opération comme étant une opération déterministe
sur un système ayant quatre états classiques
que nous avons décidé de nommer
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 et 1,1.
Voici un autre exemple d'une
opération probabiliste sur deux bits, qui n'est pas une opération déterministe cette fois.
L'opération met Y égal à X avec une probabilité d'un demi et sinon ça se passe dans l'autre sens et elle met X égal à Y.
Cette opération n'a pas de nom particulier, c'est juste un exemple.
Et voici la représentation
matricielle de cette opération.
Tu peux voir qu'elle peut être exprimée comme une moyenne de deux matrices, l'une qui représente l'opération
déterministe
où Y est mis à la valeur
stockée dans X et l'autre qui met
X égal à Y.
Donc ici nous voyons que nous pouvons prendre des moyennes de matrices stochastiques pour en obtenir de nouvelles tout comme nous l'avions dans la leçon précédente.
Maintenant, considérons
la question suivante. Suppose que nous avons deux
opérations probabilistes chacune sur son propre système
décrites comme d'habitude par des matrices stochastiques
et pour être précis, supposons que M est
une opération probabiliste
sur un système X et N est une
opération probabiliste sur un système Y.
La question est si nous
effectuons simultanément M sur X et N sur Y, comment décrivons-nous
l'effet que cela a
sur le système composé XY ?
En réfléchissant à cela
intuitivement un instant, si nous effectuons simultanément les deux opérations sur leurs propres systèmes respectifs,
alors nous effectuons en fait
une opération sur le système composé, donc elle doit être décrite
par une certaine matrice stochastique.
La réponse courte à cette
question est que la matrice est obtenue en prenant un produit tensoriel, pas entre des vecteurs comme
nous en avons parlé plus tôt,
WEBVTT
mais entre des matrices dans ce
cas, les matrices M et N.
Donc prenons quelques instants
pour discuter des produits tensoriels de matrices et ensuite nous
reviendrons à cette question.
Voici la définition
du produit tensoriel entre des matrices et
elle est très analogue au produit tensoriel entre des vecteurs.
Si nous supposons que les deux
matrices avec lesquelles nous travaillons sont écrites sous les formes que tu vois ici de sorte que les entrées de M sont
notées alpha ab avec a et b
parcourant un certain ensemble d'états classiques sigma et les entrées de N sont
notées beta cd avec c et d
parcourant un certain ensemble d'états classiques gamma.
Alors le produit de M et N est la matrice que tu vois ici.
Ce que nous avons est similaire
au produit tensoriel entre vecteurs.
les lignes et colonnes de M tensoriel N correspondent à des paires d'états classiques qui sont écrits comme des chaînes ici,
et les entrées sont des produits des entrées correspondantes de M et N.
Voici une autre façon de l'écrire en termes des entrées individuelles
de ces matrices.
L'entrée ac bd de M tensoriel N est le produit de l'entrée ab
de M et de l'entrée cd de N.
Il y a une autre façon de
décrire M tensoriel N, qui est que c'est la
matrice unique qui transforme tout vecteur de la forme Phi tensoriel Psi
en le produit tensoriel de M appliqué à Phi avec N appliqué à Psi, et cela doit être vrai pour tout choix
de ces vecteurs Phi et Psi.
Une façon de penser à
cela est que le produit tensoriel de matrices s'entend parfaitement avec le produit tensoriel entre vecteurs.
C'est une équation que tu
espèrerais naturellement être vraie et en effet elle l'est.
En termes de matrices
écrites explicitement, nous pouvons définir le produit
tensoriel comme tu le vois ici.
Il y a beaucoup de points dans cette équation et ils sont censés
illustrer le motif, qui est le même motif
que nous avions pour les vecteurs sauf que maintenant nous avons des lignes et des colonnes
par opposition aux seuls vecteurs colonnes.
Si ce n'est pas clair, l'
exemple suivant peut aider.
Ici nous parlons de
le produit tensoriel de deux matrices deux par deux.
Nous écrivons d'abord quatre
copies de la seconde matrice, une pour chaque entrée de la première matrice.
Nous multiplions chacune de ces
copies de la seconde matrice par l'entrée correspondante
de la première matrice,
et ensuite nous assemblons tout en
une seule matrice quatre par quatre comme tu le vois ici.
Nous pouvons aussi définir le
produit tensoriel de trois matrices ou plus de façon analogue et peut-être la façon la plus simple de l'exprimer
c'est comme tu le vois ici
où nous avons une formule pour chaque entrée du produit tensoriel, qui est simplement le produit des entrées correspondantes.
Tu peux aussi définir le produit tensoriel de trois matrices ou plus récursivement en termes du produit
tensoriel de seulement deux matrices tout comme nous l'avions pour les vecteurs.
Et une dernière remarque est
que le produit tensoriel de matrices est multiplicatif, ce qui signifie qu'un
produit de produits tensoriels
est égal au produit
tensoriel des produits.
Tu peux considérer
cela comme une généralisation de la formule vue il y a quelques instants pour l'action d'un produit tensoriel de matrices
sur un produit tensoriel de vecteurs. Et encore une fois, c'est quelque chose que nous
espèrerions certainement être vrai et nous pouvons être contents que ce soit le cas
et nous utiliserons ce
fait chaque fois que nécessaire.
Et maintenant nous pouvons revenir à
la question d'avant qui demande comment nous décrivons
l'effet d'effectuer une opération M sur un système X
et une opération N sur le système Y ensemble comme une opération
sur le système composé XY.
Et la réponse à cette
question est que l'action est décrite par le
produit tensoriel de M et N.
Les produits tensoriels représentent l'indépendance cette fois entre les opérations par opposition à ce que nous avons vu
avant pour les vecteurs de probabilité.
Voici un exemple rapide. Suppose que nous effectuons
l'opération probabiliste décrite par cette matrice sur un bit X.
C'est en fait une opération
que nous avons vue dans la leçon un et nous effectuons simultanément
une opération NOT sur un bit Y.
L'opération combinée sur la paire XY est donc représentée par le produit tensoriel des matrices correspondant à ces deux opérations.
Voici celle sur X et
voici l'opération NOT sur Y et nous obtenons cette matrice
que tu vois ici.
Et tu peux voir qu'en effet
c'est une matrice stochastique et ce sera toujours le cas.
Le produit tensoriel de deux
matrices stochastiques quelconques ou d'un nombre quelconque de matrices stochastiques d'ailleurs sera toujours stochastique.
Il est très courant
de se retrouver dans une situation où une opération est
effectuée sur un système et rien n'est fait à un autre système.
Dans cette situation, nous suivons exactement la même prescription en comprenant que ne rien faire est représenté par la matrice identité.
Par exemple, si nous avons deux bits X et
Y et que nous réinitialisons le bit X à l'état zéro, ce qui est la même chose
que d'effectuer la fonction constante
zéro sur X et que nous ne faisons rien à Y, alors l'opération résultante sur la paire XY
WEBVTT
est représentée par ce
produit tensoriel ici.
Tout cela se généralise
à n'importe quel nombre de systèmes et nous verrons des exemples supplémentaires quand nous passerons au contexte quantique, ce qui fonctionne exactement de la même façon
sauf que nous avons des matrices unitaires plutôt que des matrices stochastiques, et c'est suffisant pour l'information classique pour l'instant.
Maintenant nous allons porter notre attention
sur l'information quantique et comment elle fonctionne pour des systèmes multiples.
Le motif est le même qu'il
l'était pour l'information classique.
Nous pouvons considérer des systèmes quantiques multiples comme des systèmes composés uniques et appliquer ce que nous savons
de la leçon précédente.
Encore une fois, les produits tensoriels
joueront un rôle clé et globalement nous obtenons une description de comment l'information quantique
fonctionne pour des systèmes multiples.
C'est très analogue
et mathématiquement similaire à ce que nous venons de voir pour
l'information classique.
Nous allons commencer avec les états quantiques.
Les états quantiques de systèmes multiples sont représentés par des vecteurs colonnes ayant des entrées de nombres complexes
et une norme euclidienne égale à un
tout comme les états quantiques
des systèmes individuels.
Cette fois les indices des
vecteurs d'état quantique correspondent au produit cartésien des ensembles d'états classiques
des systèmes individuels
parce qu'encore une fois, c'est
l'ensemble d'états classiques du système composé.
Par exemple, si X et Y sont des qubits, alors l'ensemble d'états classiques
de la paire XY ensemble est le produit cartésien de
l'alphabet binaire avec lui-même,
que nous pouvons considérer comme
l'ensemble de toutes les chaînes binaires de longueur deux.
Donc ces vecteurs que tu vois ici sont tous des exemples de vecteurs d'état quantique de XY.
Si nous le voulons, nous pouvons alternativement écrire
ces vecteurs comme ça où nous avons un ket séparé
pour chaque qubit
où le produit tensoriel
entre eux est implicite.
Ou nous pouvons aussi écrire le
symbole de produit tensoriel explicitement comme ça si tu préfères.
Et une autre option est
de mettre en indice les kets avec les noms des systèmes
qu'ils représentent comme ça.
Et tu peux le faire avec
le symbole de produit tensoriel ou sans.
Ça peut parfois être très utile pour garder les choses claires.
Ce sont juste différents styles pour exprimer les mêmes vecteurs et nous pouvons choisir celui que nous voulons ou celui que nous préférons ou
celui qui a le plus de sens
pour la situation en question. Quand les choses deviennent plus
compliquées par exemple, nous pourrions décider qu'un de
ces styles ajoute de la clarté
et nous sommes libres de faire
le choix que nous voulons.
Les produits tensoriels de vecteurs d'état quantique sont aussi des vecteurs d'état quantique.
Dans le cas de deux systèmes par exemple, si Phi est un vecteur d'état quantique
d'un système X et Psi est un vecteur d'état quantique
d'un système Y,
alors le produit tensoriel de Phi et Psi est un vecteur d'état quantique de XY.
Nous appelons des états comme ça des états produits et similairement à ce que nous avons vu dans le contexte probabiliste classique, ils représentent l'indépendance
entre les systèmes X et Y.
Ainsi par exemple, si une personne a un laboratoire
dans une partie du monde et crée un système X et l'initialise à l'état quantique Phi
et une autre personne dans
une autre partie du monde initialise indépendamment un système Y à l'état quantique Psi,
alors si nous choisissons de considérer XY comme formant un seul système même s'il est en deux parties ou dans différentes parties du monde,
alors le système composé XY est
dans l'état Phi tensoriel Psi.
Tout cela se généralise à
plus de deux systèmes de façon naturelle.
Si nous avons des
états quantiques Psi1 jusqu'à PsiN de systèmes séparés Xn jusqu'à Xn, alors le produit tensoriel de ces n vecteurs
représente un état quantique, qui est encore appelé un état produit du système composé X1 jusqu'à Xn.
Voici un exemple d'un
état quantique de deux qubits.
Bien que ça ne soit pas
évident immédiatement. C'est un exemple d'un état produit parce que nous pouvons l'écrire
comme un produit tensoriel comme tu le vois ici.
Donc c'est un exemple d'un
état produit indépendamment de la façon dont il est écrit, ce qui est pertinent c'est s'il est
possible ou non de l'écrire comme un produit tensoriel.
Cet état quantique, cependant, qui est encore un état de deux
qubits n'est pas un état produit.
Il est similaire dans l'esprit à
l'exemple que nous avons vu dans le contexte probabiliste de deux bits aléatoires parfaitement corrélés
et le même argument révèle qu'il ne peut pas être écrit
comme un produit tensoriel.
Donc déplaçons ça ici et examinons l'argument un peu plus en détail.
Imaginons que nous
pourrions écrire cet état comme un produit tensoriel de
deux vecteurs Phi et Psi.
L'entrée correspondant
à l'état classique 0,1 est zéro pour ce vecteur, ce que nous pouvons voir juste en le regardant.
Cela impliquerait cependant, si le vecteur était un produit
tensoriel de deux vecteurs que l'entrée zéro de Phi
fois l'entrée un de Psi
serait égale à zéro, mais cela signifie que soit
l'entrée zéro de Phi soit l'entrée un de Psi est égale à zéro
ou les deux pourraient être égales à zéro, mais cela contredit le fait
que ces deux produits ici doivent être tous les deux non nuls.
WEBVTT
Ils sont égaux à un
sur racine carrée de deux. L'argument est en fait pratiquement
identique à ce que nous avions dans le contexte probabiliste.
Il n'y a rien d'uniquement
quantique là-dedans.
Dans tous les cas, ce que nous trouvons est que l'état original n'est pas un état produit.
Remarque qu'il n'est pas important
que ces deux nombres ici soient un sur racine carrée de deux.
Tout ce qui importe c'est que
les deux valeurs soient non nulles.
Cet état quantique particulier
est un très intéressant. C'est un exemple d'un
état intriqué de deux qubits.
Nous parlerons plus de
l'intrication plus tard dans la série.
L'intrication peut être compliquée, en particulier quand nous
parlons d'états quantiques dans la formulation générale
de l'information quantique,
mais ici dans la description simplifiée de l'information quantique l'intrication est équivalente à l'absence d'indépendance.
Donc pour un vecteur d'état quantique,
s'il n'est pas un état produit, c'est un état intriqué
et cet état particulier
est communément considéré comme
l'exemple archétypal d'un état quantique intriqué.
Et en fait, nous pensons parfois
à cet état comme représentant une unité d'intrication, en particulier quand nous
réfléchissons à l'intrication
comme une ressource qui peut
être utilisée pour faire des choses intéressantes.
L'état quantique dont
nous venons de parler est l'un des quatre états dits états de Bell, que tu peux voir ici
avec les noms
qui sont couramment utilisés pour ces états, Phi plus, Phi moins,
Psi plus et Psi moins.
Ils sont tous intriqués
et ils forment bien une base pour l'espace de tous les
vecteurs représentant des états de deux qubits.
Donc ces quatre vecteurs ensemble
sont appelés la base de Bell.
C'est une collection d'états quantiques
très couramment rencontrée nommée
en l'honneur de John Bell, qui était un physicien ayant fait de
très importantes contributions
à l'étude de l'intrication dans les années 1960.
Voici quelques exemples bien connus d'états quantiques de trois qubits.
Le premier est appelé un état GHZ.
Il est un peu comme l'état Phi
plus que nous venons de voir sauf pour trois qubits au lieu de deux.
Et le second exemple est appelé un état W et il ressemble à ce que tu vois ici, donc il est uniforme sur
les trois chaînes binaires
de longueur trois qui ont
exactement un bit mis à un.
Aucun de ces états n'est un état produit et ils ont tous deux des propriétés intéressantes et apparaissent assez couramment comme exemples, donc il est utile de les connaître
et nous les reverrons.
Ensuite nous parlerons de
mesures de systèmes dans des états quantiques.
En suivant le même raisonnement
que nous avons suivi jusqu'ici dans la leçon, qui est de considérer des systèmes multiples
comme s'ils étaient des systèmes individuels. Nous arrivons immédiatement à une description de comment les mesures de
systèmes quantiques multiples fonctionnent
à condition que tous les
systèmes soient mesurés.
C'est-à-dire que si nous avons un
vecteur d'état quantique Psi qui représente un état quantique
d'un n-uplet de systèmes
X1 jusqu'à Xn et que nous mesurons
l'ensemble du système composé, ce qui est équivalent à mesurer
chacun des systèmes individuels, alors chaque n-uplet possible
d'états classiques sera le résultat de la mesure
avec une probabilité égale à
la valeur absolue au carré de l'entrée de Psi qui
correspond à ce n-uplet.
Par exemple, si nous avons
une paire de systèmes XY dans cet état quantique ici, alors si nous mesurons les deux systèmes,
alors nous obtiendrons le résultat zéro cœur ce qui signifie zéro pour la mesure de X et cœur pour la mesure de Y
avec une probabilité de neuf vingt-cinquièmes et nous obtiendrons le résultat un
pique avec une probabilité de 16/25.
C'est vraiment assez simple. Nous ignorons essentiellement le fait que ce sont deux systèmes séparés et nous les considérons comme
un seul système,
mais cela soulève la
question naturelle suivante, que nous avons déjà considérée
dans le contexte classique.
Suppose que nous avons deux systèmes X et Y qui sont collectivement
dans un certain état quantique et que nous ne mesurons pas les deux, mais
nous mesurons seulement un système.
Disons que nous mesurons le système X et ne faisons rien à Y.
Bien sûr, nous pouvons aussi demander ce qui se passe si nous mesurons Y et non
X et plus généralement ce qui se passe si nous avons
trois systèmes ou plus
et que nous mesurons un sous-ensemble propre d'entre eux. Mais une fois que nous avons une
réponse à cette question, nous aurons des réponses à
ces questions aussi.
Nous savons qu'en général
un vecteur d'état quantique de la paire XY prend la
forme que tu vois ici, en supposant comme d'habitude que sigma et gamma
sont les ensembles d'états classiques
de X et Y respectivement.
Les entrées de ce vecteur sont
notées alpha ab parcourant tous les choix possibles de a et b,
et ils peuvent être n'importe quel nombre complexe qui cause ce vecteur
à être un vecteur unitaire.
Nous savons déjà que si
les deux systèmes sont mesurés, alors nous obtenons les probabilités pour les différents résultats possibles
WEBVTT
en prenant la valeur absolue au carré de l'entrée correspondante.
Et donc si seulement X est mesuré, alors la probabilité d'
obtenir un résultat particulier a est donnée par cette expression,
nous additionnons simplement tous
les résultats possibles b, qui pourraient être obtenus
si Y était aussi mesuré même si ce n'est pas le cas.
L'idée est la même que dans
le contexte probabiliste.
La probabilité d'obtenir
un résultat particulier quand X est mesuré ne peut
pas dépendre du fait que Y ait aussi été mesuré.
Donc ça nous dit quelles
sont les probabilités pour les différents résultats possibles.
De plus, il y aura un
changement dans l'état de Y par suite d'avoir
effectué cette mesure sur X et d'avoir obtenu un résultat particulier.
Donc voyons comment ça fonctionne.
Similairement à ce que nous avons fait dans
le contexte probabiliste, nous pouvons exprimer le
vecteur d'état quantique Psi comme tu le vois ici
où Phi a est ce vecteur pour chaque choix d'un état classique a du système X,
nous utilisons la bilinéarité
du produit tensoriel comme avant.
Seulement maintenant nous avons choisi de nommer
ces différents vecteurs Phi a, juste par commodité.
Nous avons déjà observé que la probabilité que la mesure donne
chaque résultat possible a est comme tu le vois ici,
mais maintenant nous pouvons voir que cette probabilité est égale à la norme euclidienne
au carré du vecteur Phi a,
et maintenant par suite de la mesure de X donnant un résultat particulier a, nous avons que l'état quantique
du système composé XY
devient cet état que
tu vois ici.
Tout comme nous l'avions pour les systèmes individuels, l'état s'effondre en essence, mais il ne s'effondre pas
entièrement en général,
il s'effondre seulement autant qu'il doit le faire pour être cohérent
avec la mesure de X donnant le résultat a.
L'état quantique de Y devient Phi a normalisé ce qui signifie que nous
divisons par sa norme euclidienne
pour qu'il devienne un vecteur unitaire. C'est analogue à ce qui s'est passé dans le
contexte probabiliste où au lieu de diviser
par la norme euclidienne,
nous avons divisé par la somme
des entrées de Phi a pour obtenir un vecteur de probabilité.
Mais ici parce que nous
parlons d'états quantiques, nous divisons par la norme euclidienne
pour obtenir un vecteur d'état quantique.
Examinons quelques exemples pour voir comment ça fonctionne
pour un état spécifique.
Voici l'état que nous allons considérer. Nous supposons que X et Y sont des qubits et qu'ils sont dans cet état particulier Psi.
Et supposons que X est mesuré.
Nous commençons par écrire les
états Psi comme tu le vois ici, en isolant effectivement les
facteurs de base standard de X
et en les mettant en produit tensoriel avec ce dont nous avons besoin pour obtenir l'état original.
Tout comme dans la description générale
de l'instant.
La probabilité d'obtenir le résultat zéro est la norme euclidienne au carré
de ce vecteur ici.
La chose que nous mettons en produit tensoriel avec le ket zéro dans notre expression du vecteur Psi.
Et donc la probabilité est trois quarts et conditionnellement à
l'obtention du résultat zéro.
L'état quantique de
la paire XY devient celui-ci où nous normalisons le
vecteur mis en produit tensoriel avec le ket zéro,
et c'est équivalent à
diviser par la racine carrée de la probabilité que
nous venons de calculer.
Nous pouvons ensuite simplifier
et voici ce que nous obtenons.
La probabilité d'obtenir le
résultat de mesure un est calculée de façon similaire.
Nous prenons la norme euclidienne au carré
de ce vecteur ici. La chose mise en produit tensoriel avec le ket
un dans notre expression de Psi
et la probabilité résultante
est un quart, ce qui doit être le cas bien sûr, parce que nos probabilités
doivent sommer à un.
Dans ce cas, l'état quantique de XY devient celui-ci où encore une fois nous normalisons en divisant par la norme euclidienne
de sorte que nous obtenons ce vecteur d'état quantique
comme résultat.
La même méthode est utilisée
de façon symétrique, si Y est mesuré au lieu de X.
Voici le vecteur d'état quantique original, et cette fois parce que Y
est mesuré au lieu de X,
nous exprimons le vecteur Psi
comme tu le vois ici, où cette fois nous isolons les
vecteurs de base standard de Y
plutôt que de X en les mettant en produit tensoriel
avec ce dont nous avons besoin pour obtenir une expression de Psi.
En effectuant le calcul, que tu peux vérifier en
mettant la vidéo sur pause si tu veux.
Nous voyons que la probabilité
d'obtenir le résultat zéro est Phi8 cette fois, et voici
le vecteur d'état quantique
qui résulte conditionnellement
à l'obtention de ce résultat.
Et la probabilité d'obtenir le
résultat un est trois huitièmes, dans ce cas voici
notre vecteur d'état quantique.
Tu peux utiliser exactement la même méthode si tu as plus de deux systèmes et que n'importe quel sous-ensemble propre
d'entre eux est mesuré.
WEBVTT
Et il y a un exemple
dans le contenu du manuel pour cette leçon que tu peux
consulter si tu es intéressé.
En bref, nous pouvons toujours diviser les systèmes en deux collections séparées, ceux qui sont mesurés
et ceux qui ne le sont pas.
Et une fois que nous avons fait ça, nous nous appuyons sur la méthode
méthode que je viens de décrire, et c'est comme les mesures pour des systèmes quantiques multiples fonctionnent.
Et maintenant enfin, nous passons aux opérations unitaires
sur des systèmes multiples.
En utilisant la même idée de base que des systèmes multiples peuvent être considérés comme des systèmes composés uniques.
Nous concluons ce que tu vois
écrit ici à l'écran, les opérations quantiques sur des systèmes composés sont représentées par des matrices unitaires
tout comme nous l'avons pour les systèmes individuels et spécifiquement les lignes et colonnes de ces matrices unitaires correspondent au produit cartésien
des ensembles d'états classiques de quelle que soit la collection de
systèmes dont nous parlons.
Par exemple, si nous avons un système X
dont les états classiques sont un, deux et trois et Y est un qubit,
alors la matrice que tu vois ici est un exemple d'une matrice unitaire qui représente une
opération sur la paire XY.
Les détails de comment nous
ordonnons les produits cartésiens dont nous avons parlé avant n'ont pas vraiment d'importance pour
cet exemple, c'est juste une matrice six par six
qui est unitaire.
Il n'y a rien de spécial là-dedans, bien qu'elle soit construite à partir de
quelques matrices importantes.
Le point est que tu pourrais
choisir n'importe quelle matrice unitaire six par six et elle représenterait
une opération unitaire sur XY.
Si nous appliquons une collection d'
opérations unitaires indépendamment chacune sur son propre système, alors l'action de toutes ensemble
sur le système composé est
donnée par le produit tensoriel.
Et ici à l'écran tu peux voir un énoncé plus précis
de ce fait.
Si nos opérations unitaires sont décrites par les matrices unitaires U1 jusqu'à Un, une pour chacun de nos systèmes,
alors l'action combinée
sur le système composé est donnée par le produit
tensoriel de U1 jusqu'à Un.
Encore une fois, similairement à ce que nous avions dans le contexte probabiliste, un exemple important est que
nous appliquons une certaine opération unitaire
U à un système X et nous ne
faisons rien à un autre système Y.
L'opération sur XY que nous obtenons est U mis en produit tensoriel avec la matrice identité.
La matrice identité
décrit ne rien faire à Y.
Parfois il est utile d'écrire explicitement que cette matrice identité
correspond au système Y, juste pour rendre les formules plus claires.
Et une option est de
donner à la matrice identité un indice comme ça qui indique le système sur lequel elle agit.
Quand c'est suffisamment clair, cependant, nous ne prenons généralement pas la peine d'un indice, mais quand les choses deviennent plus compliquées, ça peut être très utile.
Et nous pouvons aussi considérer
le cas symétrique où une certaine opération unitaire
V est appliquée à Y et rien n'est fait à X,
et cette fois l'opération unitaire
résultante sur XY, est représentée par ce
produit tensoriel ici.
Et encore une fois, nous pouvons mettre un indice sur la
matrice identité si ça aide.
Voici quelques exemples spécifiques.
Si X et Y sont des qubits et que nous
effectuons une opération Hadamard sur X et ne faisons rien à Y, nous obtenons la matrice que tu vois ici.
Si d'autre part, nous effectuons l'opération Hadamard sur Y et ne faisons rien à X, l'ordre du produit
tensoriel est inversé.
Et donc nous obtenons la matrice
que tu vois ici.
Toutes les opérations unitaires
sur un système composé ne peuvent pas être exprimées comme un produit tensoriel.
Si nous avons un produit tensoriel,
alors nous avons l'indépendance.
Et il y a des exemples assez
fondamentaux d'opérations qui certes
n'agissent pas indépendamment sur des systèmes multiples.
Par exemple, si X et Y ont
le même ensemble d'états classiques, qui pourrait être n'importe quel
ensemble d'états classiques sigma,
alors nous pouvons réfléchir à l'opération
d'échange sur la paire XY.
Cette opération ne change pas l'ordre des deux systèmes, nous avons toujours X à
gauche et Y à droite, mais elle représente
l'échange des contenus
des deux systèmes. Tu peux voir ça exprimé ici
sous la forme d'une équation où nous avons un produit
tensoriel de deux états quantiques.
Une autre façon de l'écrire c'est
une matrice comme nous le voyons ici.
La façon de penser
à cette description est qu'elle te dit ce qui se passe pour les vecteurs de base standard.
Et une fois que nous savons ce qui se passe
pour les vecteurs de base standard, nous savons ce qui se passe pour
des états quantiques arbitraires par linéarité,
ce qui est en fait aussi vrai pour
cette expression ici.
Donc cette opération particulière ici est en fait une opération déterministe ainsi qu'une opération unitaire.
Si X et Y sont des qubits, par exemple, nous obtenons cette représentation matricielle
ici.
Voici une connexion intéressante
entre l'opération d'échange et les quatre états de Bell, qui sont montrés ici
pour plus de commodité.
L'opération d'échange laisse les
trois premiers inchangés, mais elle met un signe moins devant l'état Psi moins,
WEBVTT
donc il y a quelque chose
de spécial avec celui-là.
Tu peux vérifier ces équations directement en regardant ces vecteurs et en considérant ce qui se passe
pour les états de base standard
échanger les deux états classiques pour les trois premiers états de Bell
ne fait rien, nous obtenons le même état dont nous sommes partis.
Dans le quatrième cas cependant, le signe moins passe effectivement
d'un terme à l'autre quand nous effectuons l'échange des états classiques,
et c'est équivalent à multiplier le vecteur par moins un.
Donc effectuer l'opération d'échange fait en quelque sorte ressortir un signe moins
de ce quatrième état de Bell.
Nous aurons plus à dire à propos de
ces équations plus tard, mais passons maintenant à
un autre type d'opération, qui est une opération contrôlée.
Nous allons supposer que X est un qubit et Y est n'importe quel système que tu veux.
Si U est une opération unitaire sur Y, alors une opération U contrôlée sur XY est l'opération
exprimée ici.
D'abord, en utilisant la notation directe et ensuite en utilisant ce qu'on
appelle une matrice par blocs tu imagines simplement remplir cette plus grande matrice
avec les plus petites où ces zéros représentent vraiment des matrices
remplies de zéros.
Donc chacun de ces quatre blocs représente une matrice ayant un nombre
de lignes et de colonnes qui correspond au nombre
d'états classiques de Y.
L'idée d'une opération contrôlée, que nous avons déjà rencontrée
dans le contexte classique quand nous avons discuté d'une
opération NOT contrôlé,
est que si X est mis à zéro,
alors rien ne se passe à Y.
Mais si X est mis à un,
alors U est appliqué à Y.
Donc X est appelé le qubit de contrôle, et Y est appelé le système cible, qui en général ne
doit pas être un qubit.
Pour un exemple spécifique,
que je viens de mentionner, nous avons une opération NOT contrôlé.
Si le premier qubit est mis
à zéro, rien ne se passe. Et si le premier qubit est mis à un, alors une opération NOT ou équivalemment,
une opération sigma X est
appliquée au second qubit.
Et voici sa représentation matricielle.
Nous parlons ici de deux qubits, donc nous pourrions tout aussi bien
décider que le second qubit est le contrôle et le
premier est la cible.
Pour décrire cette opération, nous échangeons simplement l'ordre
dans le produit tensoriel, et le résultat est la matrice
que tu vois ici.
Si au lieu d'une opération NOT contrôlé, nous considérons un contrôle sigma
Z ou une opération Z contrôlé.
Nous obtenons cette représentation
matricielle ici. Et pour celle-ci, peu importe en fait
lequel est le contrôle et lequel est la cible.
Nous obtenons le même résultat dans les deux cas.
Nous pouvons aller plus loin et nous pouvons considérer une opération d'échange contrôlé.
Et ici nous parlons
d'échanger deux qubits, donc nous finissons avec trois qubits quand nous incluons le qubit de contrôle.
Chaque représentation matricielle
ressemble à ça.
C'est une opération assez spéciale et elle est connue comme une opération Fredkin, ou plus communément un gate Fredkin.
Quand nous y réfléchissons
comme un gate dans un circuit, nous discuterons des circuits dans la prochaine leçon.
Le dernier exemple est une opération
NOT contrôlé-contrôlé, qui est encore une
opération sur trois qubits.
Et voici sa représentation matricielle. Cette opération est bien mieux
connue comme une opération Toffoli ou un gate Toffoli.
Nous la discuterons davantage
et nous verrons pourquoi à la fois elle et l'opération Fredkin sont des
opérations très importantes dans une leçon ultérieure.
Et c'est la fin de la deuxième leçon. Dans cette leçon, nous avons discuté de comment l'information quantique fonctionne pour des systèmes multiples.
J'espère que tu te joindras à moi pour
la troisième leçon bientôt, qui porte sur les circuits quantiques,
protocoles et jeux.
Au revoir jusqu'à la prochaine.